Now we have had some experience with D3 in the console.
I wanted to cover some of the basic structure of a typical D3 visualization.
I will be explaining an example from Mike Bostock's tutorial,
on creating a basic bar chart and the fundamentals of D3.
I chose this example for three reasons.
The first, is the tutorial is very clear and
thoroughly explains all of the fundamental concepts of D3.
Once you finish the tutorial, if you decide to go through it and
create this bar chart you see here.
You will have been exposed to all of the concepts in D3 necessary to build
more complication visualizations, as you will encounter later in the course.
The second reason I wanted to go through this code and
the tutorial is that it's very easily accessible on the web, so
you can go back and review if you feel unsure about any of the concepts covered.
But also it's quite ubiquitous and
very common to other people have encountered the tutorial.
This makes it very easy to share what you've learned and
collaborate with others.
And the third reason is simply the fact that Mike Bostock is the creator if D3.
And by virtue of having built the library knows all the most important concepts.